[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und marietas lomka guten Abend das
ausgerechnet der als so verlässlich
geltende Schweizer Bankenplatz die
Weltfinanzmärkte in Atem hält und das
hätte man sich auch nicht träumen lassen
die Credit Suisse ist so ins Trudeln
geraten das Regierung und Bankenaufsicht
die Reißleine gezogen und deren
Übernahme praktisch erzwungen haben
jetzt am Abend gab es dazu die mit
Spannung erwartete Pressekonferenz die
Großbank UBS bislang Konkurrenten der
kleineren Credit Suisse muss als
Retterin einspringen auch das ist ein
erstaunlicher Vorgang Eva Schiller über
einen dramatischen Tag in Bern
Beruhigung ausstrahlen den Ruf des
Schweizer Bankenwesens retten das
versuchen sie auf den allerletzten
Drücker nach tagelangen Krisensitzungen
die UBS Bank wird die taumelnde Credit
Suisse übernehmen unterstützt vom Staat
mit 100 Milliarden Franken
Liquiditätshilfe plus 100 Milliarden
Franken Darlehen
die creditis wies war ein
unkalkulierbares Risiko für unser Land
und für den internationalen Finanzplatz
wir haben deshalb die Verantwortung
alles zu tun um eine Finanzkrise zu
verhindern er braucht diese Lösung hat
Risiken aber die Risiken für den Staat
für die SteuerzahlerInnen die
Steuerzahler sind deutlich geringer als
bei jedem anderen Szenario es ist seit
der Finanzkrise die bedeutendste
bankenfusion Europas Konkurrent UBS
kauft die Credit Suisse für drei
Milliarden Franken eine neue Schweizer
mega-bank wird entstehen auf Drängen der
Regierung hin
das ist schon eine eine Situation da
wird jemand wirklich zum Kauf getragen
bei so großen sehr international
vernetzten Banken wissen sie nie so ganz
genau was sie kaufen tatsächlich muss
die UBS ja auch etwas kaufen was sie gar
nicht vorher prüfen kann wie viele der
über 50.000 crediswies Mitarbeiter durch
die Fusion ihren Job verlieren werden
unklar und ob die Schweizer mega-fusion
die internationale Finanzwelt beruhigen
kann das wird sich morgen entscheiden
wenn die Börsen wieder öffnen
ja und unser Fachmann für Wirtschaft und
Finanzen Frank Bethmann ist bei uns im
Studio also eines war klar es musste
heute was passieren oder ja die Zeit hat
mächtig gedrängt spätestens ein paar
Stunden wenn die Märkte entfernen Ost
wieder aufmachen dann muss man das
Problem gelöst haben denn eine
unkontrolliert abstürzende credit Swiss
hätte vermutlich die nächste Bankenkrise
ausgelöst an dem Punkt waren wir heute
und dafür ist die Credit Swiss einfach
viel zu groß sie gehört zu den 30 Banken
die eben andere bei Turbulenzen
mitreißen können sie ist stark engagiert
auf dem US-amerikanischen Markt auch in
Großbritannien das sind ja große
wichtige Finanzmärkte und wenn man eins
aus der Finanzkrise von vor 15 Jahren
gelernt hat dann dass man die Kuh eben
vom Eis kriegen muss bevor die Märkte
wieder eröffnen und deswegen passieren
solche wichtigen Entscheidungen auch
meistens immer sonntags immer wieder
sonntags wenn man sich anguckt wie dann
dieser Rettungswege ist also für die UBS
ist das jetzt auch nicht gerade schön
man sich da so eine angeschlagene Bank
ans Bein binden zu müssen nee bis
zuletzt hat sie sich gegen diese
Zwangsehe auch gewährt aber sie hatte
eine gute Verhandlungsposition weil es
hieß das ist die am schnellsten machbare
Lösung jetzt und Faktor Zeit ist
natürlich jetzt ein ganz wichtiger
Faktor gewesen und deswegen hat sie sich
auch ein paar Sicherheiten einbauen
lassen unter anderem hat die Credit
Suisse ja durchaus Risiken in ihrer
Bilanz jetzt wird also der Schweizer
Staat mit 9 Milliarden dort Sicherheiten
geben und für beide Institute gibt es
ordentliche Liquiditätshilfen von 100
Milliarden also alles um zu zeigen die
Banken sind jetzt erstmal stabil nein
die Alternative wäre gewesen dass die
Schweizer Staat da direkt einsteigt
jetzt ist natürlich die große Preisfrage
reicht das also wird das jetzt diese
Moment offenbar doch sehr nervöse Märkte
beruhigen ja du sagst es ist die große
Preisfrage alle hoffen natürlich das ist
gewissermaßen die Schweizer die heute
ausgepackt worden ist das Signal die
Botschaft ist ganz klar alle Banken
können Ihre Bankgeschäfte ganz normal
weitermachen ab morgen auch die Credit
Suisse kann alle Bankgeschäfte ausführen
und die Schweizer Finanzministerin die
wir da gerade eben auch noch mal ein
Bild gesehen hatten sagte dann auch uns
ist bewusst gewesen dass das über die
Schweiz hinaus geht dass wir da
Verantwortung haben man kann auch sagen
die Reputation des Finanzplatzes Schweiz
stand auf dem Spiel denn alle hätten
natürlich gesagt in unser Geld schon
nicht mehr in der Schweiz sicher ist wo
denn dann bitte allerdings Frank danke
dir für die Einschätzung erstmal an
diesem Abend der Schweizer Banken Deal
war zweifellos die Meldung des Tages das
Bild des Tages das war das russische
Propaganda-Video das zeigen soll wie
Vladimir Putin selbst am Steuer sitzen
durch das nächtliche Mario Paul fährt
ausgerechnet Mario Paul die besetzte
Hafenstadt die die Russen in Schutt und
Asche gelegt haben ausgerechnet die
Stadt aus der nach ukrainischen Angaben
die meisten Kinder verschleppt wurden es
ist vielleicht kein Zufall dass der
Kreml dieses Video zwei Tage nach der
Verhängung des internationalen
Haftbefehls gegen Putin veröffentlicht
man könnte es auch so interpretieren
Putin zeigt der Welt den Mittelfinger
es ist ein nächtlicher Besuch den der
Kreml besonders in Szene setzt Präsident
Putin fährt selbst durch das besetzte
Mario Paul das sollen die Bilder des
russischen Staatsfernsehens zeigen diese
Gegend ist schon wieder gut aufgebaut da
sind sogar Spielplätze ja genau
Spielplätze es ist Putins erste Reise in
das von Russland kontrollierte Gebiet
mit dem russischen
vizeministerpräsidenten besichtigt er
ein neuer richtetes Wohnquartier sie
besprechen Details zum Wiederaufbau auf
einem Spielplatz
verwundert und neugierig geben sich
Anwohner die Welt Zufall den Präsidenten
bei seinem nächtlichen Besuch antreffen
diese Frau spricht von einem kleinen
Stück Paradies hier
Putin lässt sich Wohnungen zeigen danke
dass Sie gekommen sind sagt dieser Mann
all das ist erstens eine Antwort auf die
in der Gesellschaft verwurzelte
Vorstellung von Putin als bunker-oper
der nirgendwo hingeht in einem Bunker
sitzt und vor allem Angst hat und
zweitens ist es eine Antwort auf
Präsident selenskis Reisen an die Front
und US-Präsident beidens Besuch in Kiew
die ukrainische Regierung verurteilt den
Besuch auf Twitter schreibt
präsidentenberater podoljak der Mörder
von tausenden von Familien in Mario Paul
kam um die Ruinen der Stadt und ihre
Gräber zu bewundern das zerstörte Mario
Paul bleibt im russischen
Fernsehzuschauer verborgen auch das
bombardierte Theater der Stadt in dem
vor einem Jahrhunderte Zivilisten
starben die russischen Besatzer haben es
inzwischen abgerissen in der Ukraine
gehen die Kämpfe weiter wie in der Stadt
bachmut die die ukrainischen Verteidiger
weiterhin halten aber auch diese Bilder
gibt es am Wochenende kanadische Leopard
Panzer werden den Flugzeuge verladen für
die Unterstützung der Ukraine
ja und wie das Kriegsgeschehen in der
Ukraine derzeit zu bewerten ist darüber
wollen wir mit dem Militärexperten
gustav-kressel sprechen er ist Forscher
am European Council und von relations
und vor allem auch für Osteuropa und
Russland ein Experte guten Abend Herr
kressel guten Abend wie bewerten sie im
Moment die militärische Lage in der
Ukraine als Laie hat man das Gefühl da
hat sich was festgefahren da passiert
nicht richtig was also es wird furchtbar
viel gestorben und zerstört aber die
Russen kommen eigentlich nicht wirklich
voran
ja ist das angespannt die Lage nicht
wirklich voran ist natürlich auch
übertrieben es gibt neue Meldungen dass
sie im Raum sie wäre das weitergekommen
sind dass sie auch südlich vom bachmut
weitergekommen sind gleichzeitig gibt es
Meldungen im ukrainische Gegenangriffe
also ganz statisch ist die Front nicht
allerdings sind natürlich die sozusagen
die die Bilder die man bekommt nicht das
was ich wahrscheinlich viele unter der
russischen früher als Offensive erwartet
haben es ist kleinräumiger und es ist
kleinen teiliger als früher als
offensiven die etwa die Rote Armee noch
produziert hat aber wie gesagt die die
Arme Putins ist jetzt nicht die Rote
Armee sie sind ganz anderes Biest und
sie sind großen Teilen ja schon in der
ersten Runde dieses Krieges geschlagen
worden und kämpft jetzt mit Reservisten
mit Offizieren die die Ausbildung sehr
schnell durchlaufen haben müssen um
irgendwie in die Front zu kommen und das
ganze sieht dann eben dementsprechend
aus eben nicht wie ein großer durchmaß
aber auch bei der Ukraine dann sieht man
Moment noch eigentlich keine Hinweise
auf die große Gegenoffensive die
angekündigt war
da wird jetzt wahrscheinlich wie das
haben wir im letzten Jahr ja auch in
Carson oft gesehen dass da
wahrscheinlich jetzt mal mehr geredet
wird als
tatsächlich vollzogen denn die Ukraine
muss jetzt einmal die russische
Offensive abwettern muss schauen dass
ich die Gelände Gewinne in Grenzen
halten und vor allen Dingen dass die
russischen Kräfte sich abnutzen erst
wenn die geschwächt sind dann tun sich
äh Lücken in der russischen Front auf
wenn Reserven auf der russischen Seite
verbraucht sind dann hat die russische
Führung Schwierigkeiten einen Durchbruch
noch mal abzufangen und dann kann man
diese Offensive starten dann kann man
auch mit einem Durchbruch mit einem
kleinen Zusammenbruch der russischen
Frauen die russischen Kräfte weiter
zurückdrängen weil sie dann eben zu
einem späteren Zeitpunkt wenn sie
abgenutzter sind nicht mehr die Reserven
und nicht mehr die Handlungsmöglichkeit
haben darauf zu reagieren
nutzen sich natürlich auch ab in dieser
Schlachtung machen Mut
sie müssen sich hier sie müssen sich
auch an anderen Stellen dieser dombas
Front an also das ist ein sehr stark
bespielter Bogen wo auf etwa 80 km Front
fast ein Drittel der ukrainischen Armee
eingesetzt ist das abnutzungsverhältnis
spricht aber zur Zeit noch im Großen und
Ganzen jetzt nicht unbedingt in
besonderen aber im Großen und Ganzen für
die Ukraine allerdings es werden
wahrscheinlich noch zwei drei harte
Monate nicht Wochen sondern Monate bevor
man die russischen Kräfte soweit
abgenutzt hat dass sie zu dünn sind dass
sich eine offensive lohnt eine größere
Offensive nun war ja das große Thema
diese Woche die Ankündigung Polens ähm
Kampfflugzeuge zu schicken die mit 29
welche Rolle können die spielen bei
einer Offensive oder dienen die eher
dazu zur Luft Verteidigung die dienen
eher der Luftverteidigung ein nicht
unerheblicher Teil der Drohne
normalflugkörper die gegen sie wieder
Infrastruktur abgeschossen werden ja
Jagdflugzeugen abgeschossen in dem Sinn
ist es wichtig dass die Ukraine eine
Jagdwaffe hat die
einsatzfähig ist und die über genügend
Maschinen hat verfügt man hat in der
Vergangenheit schon Flugzeuge geliefert
allerdings unter der Hand die wurden als
Ersatzteile in die Ukraine geliefert und
dort zusammengebaut und
dann gab es plötzlich Zeiten wo die
Ukraine mehr mit 29 zur Verfügung hatte
er sie vor dem Krieg hat allerdings
läuft natürlich jetzt auch die
Diskussion um westliche Flugzeugmuster
vor allen Dingen in den USA um die
Freigabe von F16 und deshalb ist
natürlich Polen und die Slowakei die
hier ganz demonstrativ zusammen
auftreten und sagen schaut her wir
liefern Kampfflugzeuge und wer Enden
morgen auch nicht im dritten Weltkrieg
ähm Herr beiden schau auf uns das geht
so auch du kannst das schaffen
danke für das Gespräch vielen herzlichen
Dank
immerhin das getreideabkommen zwischen
Russland und der Ukraine wurde
verlängert andernfalls wäre es heute
ausgelaufen allerdings streiten Moskau
und Kiew noch darüber für welchen
Zeitraum die Verlängerung gilt
vermittelt worden war es von den
Vereinten Nationen und der Türkei in
deren Gewässer die Schiffe kontrolliert
werden beide Länder Russland wie die
Ukraine sind wichtige weltexporteure für
Getreide Sonnenblumenöl und andere
Agrarprodukte vor allem afrikanische
Länder hängen von diesen Lieferungen ab
russland hatte die ukrainischen Häfen
zunächst vollständig blockiert mit dem
Abkommen kann die Ukraine wenigstens
einen Teil ihres Getreides verkaufen
aber unter sehr schweren Bedingungen
eine Brühl hat in der Ukraine einen
Landwirt besucht der davon erzählt
was Ziel bist du wie zeigt uns stolz
seinen Hof seit 30 Jahren
bewirtschaftete ihn 1500 Hektar
in der Ukraine
die Ernte vom Vorjahr hat er nur zum
Teil verkauft die Preise für den
Transport seien zu hoch er selbst
bekomme zu wenig für Mais und
weizenia die Transportlogistik ist sehr
teuer geworden also die Lieferungen weil
so viele Häfen gesperrt sind sind die
Lieferungen mit der Eisenbahn oder mit
dem LKW zwei bis dreimal teurer geworden
trotzdem setzt er auf das
getreideabkommen damit der Export über
die Häfen der Region Odessa weiterlaufen
kann er verkauft sein Getreide vor allem
in die Nachbarländer Ungarn Polen ins
Baltikum
und wir haben den Verfall der Währung
erlebt ungefähr 70% gegenüber dem Dollar
das hat vor allem mit dem Krieg zu tun
der auch in peremocher Spuren
hinterlassen hat direkt nach
Kriegsbeginn hatten die Russen das Dorf
von vasil bis sowie besetzt die Felder
vermiet ich habe diesen Weg zwei drei
Mal schon vorher benutzt aber dann
regnet es und der Boden war weich das
Auto ist nach rechts gerutscht weil es
matschig war und mit dem Rad bin ich auf
die Mine gekommen die Mine ist
explodiert und das Auto wurde total
zerstört
bist du wie hat überlebt die Arbeit auf
dem Feld geht einfach weiter für ihn und
seine Mitarbeiter früher als sonst im
Jahr sehen Sie in peremocha Weizen aus
die Getreideproduktion ist eine der
wichtigsten Branchen in der Ukraine in
der sehr viele Menschen tätig sind das
sind Millionen von Beschäftigten und
Milliarden von Einnahmen in Form von
Devisen und Steuern
auf dem Feld in perimocha wissen Sie wie
wichtig ihre Arbeit ist gerade in
Kriegszeiten in denen andere Landwirte
an der Front kämpfen oder ihre Höfe
verlassen mussten weil die Russen sie
besetzt haben
die meisten Bauern in der Ukraine sehen
im Moment nicht aber die Menschen müssen
von irgendwas leben wenn wir hier nicht
sehen können dann bleibt die ganze Welt
hungrig
Weizen für den Weltmarkt in diesem Jahr
hoffen Sie in peremocha soll alles
besser werden
und jetzt geht's erstmal mit den
Nachrichten weiter und mit Heinz Wolf
zehn Tage nach dem Amoklauf in einem
Hamburger Gemeindezentrum der Zeugen
Jehovas wurde heute der Opfer gedacht
die großen christlichen Kirchen hatten
zu einem ökumenischen Gottesdienst in
der Hauptkirche St Petri eingeladen
offizielle Vertreter der Zeugen Jehovas
Namen nicht teil die
Glaubensgemeinschaft will eine eigene
Trauerfeier veranstalten würdigte aber
die Anteilnahme sieben Menschen waren am
9 März getötet worden
Bundesumweltministerin Lemke hat eine
weitere Verschiebung des Atomausstiegs
in Deutschland ausgeschlossen es bleibe
beim Atomausstieg Mitte April sagte die
Grünen Politikerin den Zeitungen der
Funke Mediengruppe die drei verbliebenen
deutschen Atomkraftwerke hätten
ursprünglich schon Ende 2022 vom Netz
gehen sollen wegen der Energiekrise
verlängerte die Koalition die Laufzeiten
bis zum 15 April
in den schwierigen Beziehungen zwischen
Serbien und Kosovo gibt es offenbar
Fortschritte nach einem mit
eu-vermittlung geführten Spitzengespräch
erklärte der
EU-Außenbeauftragte Borell man habe
einen Deal grundlage ist ein von der EU
vorgelegtes Abkommen mit dem Ziel die
Beziehungen zu normalisieren 2008 hatte
das Kosovo seine Unabhängigkeit erklärt
Serbien erkennt das nicht an
bei einem schweren Erdbeben in der
Grenzregion zwischen Ecuador und Peru
sind mindestens 15 Menschen ums Leben
gekommen das Epizentrum des Bebens der
Stärke 6,8 lag im Süden Ecuadors nach
Angaben der Regierung dort wurden mehr
als 400 Menschen verletzt unter der
Gebäude Brücken und Stromleitungen
wurden demnach beschädigt oder zerstört
vor zwei Wochen feierte sich die Welt
für das New Yorker meeresschutzabkommen
das Problem ist nur dass Abkommen regelt
nicht konkret wie der Meeresboden
geschützt wird darum geht es in diesen
Tagen in Jamaika dort verhandelt die
internationale meeresbodenbehörde über
einen Antrag der es in sich hat es geht
um industriellen Tiefseebergbau in
internationalen Gewässern
ein kanadisches Unternehmen möchte am
Meeresboden im Pazifik Bergbau betreiben
mit Hilfe solcher Erntemaschinen wird
der Meeresboden abgemäht dort wo
sogenannte Manganknollen vorkommen denn
diese kartoffelgroßen Knollen stecken
voller wertvoller Metalle in flacher und
küstennahen Hoheitsgewässern wird
bereits Bergbau betrieben die für die
internationalen Gewässer zuständige
meeresbodenbehörde hatte bisher nur
Lizenzen zu Erkundung geteilt nun wird
es ernst
Meeresforscher warnen vor langfristigen
Zerstörungen an Flora und Fauna
Christian von Rechenberg
man muss tief tauchen um sie zu finden
sehr tief 5000 Meter runter zu den
Manganknollen über Jahr Millionen
gewachsen Lebensraum für zahllose Arten
die meisten weder entdeckt noch
erforscht
ganz spezifische Organismen die diese
Manganknollen als harzsubstrat sein
Lebensraum brauchen das sind so Korallen
und Schwämme die aber wieder auch ein
Habitat bilden für mobile Fauna wie
Schlangensterne und Ruder fußkrebse und
so weiter und die sind für Millionen
Jahre weg
so sieht es aus wenn eine Erntemaschine
unterwegs war das frühere Testfeld an
der belgischen Firma konnten forschende
vom GEOMAR Helmholtz-Zentrum für
ozeanforschung untersuchen was sie
fanden verheißt nichts Gutes da unten
Lokal und das eben am Ende auch auf
mehreren 100 Quadratkilometern pro Jahr
die diese abbauoperation groß sein
werden ist dann tatsächlich das Leben
für viele viele Generationen zerstört
und alles nur weil wir diese kleinen
Knubbel für die Energiewende brauchen
sagte Industrie Mangan Knollen enthalten
nämlich neben Mangan drei heiß begehrte
Metalle Kobalt Nickel und Kupfer drei
bis fünfmal mehr als vergleichbar
Vorkommen an Land
so wenn wir ehrlich sind wird ja Tiefsee
Bergbau nicht den Bergbauern Land
ersetzen sondern es wird darauf
hinauslaufen dass wir zusätzlich zu der
Zerstörung an Land auch noch die Tiefsee
zerstören und zwar überall wo
Manganknollen in den Weltmeeren
vorkommen ein Ort auf den sich viele
Staaten stürzen die Clarion clipperten
Zone die internationale
meeresbodenbehörde hat bereits Lizenzen
erteilt um hier den Abbau zunächst zu
erforschen auch Deutschland hat hier
zwei clames und sitzt mit am Tisch wenn
die meeresbodenbehörde nun entscheidet
nach welchen Regeln Tiefseebergbau
künftig in großen Stil möglich sein soll
man zweifelt
tiefste Bergbau ist laut sehr recht
grundsätzlich zulässig allerdings unter
der Voraussetzung dass schwerwiegende
Folgen für die Meeresumwelt
ausgeschlossen werden können die
Forschung die wir hier wirklich seit
vielen Jahren machen
zeigt sehr deutlich dass wir dies nicht
ausschließen können deswegen wollen
deutschland und andere Staaten wie
Frankreich einen Stopp der Abbaupläne
solange bis forschende grünes Licht
geben auch wenn das Generation dauert
doch die Zeit drängt Studien etwa der
deutschen rohstoffagentur belegen dass
in den nächsten Jahrzehnten der Bedarf
an Metallen wie etwa Kobalt um ein
Vielfaches steigen wird Recycling wäre
der Klügere Ausweg sagen Kritiker und
technischer Fortschritt da ist der
technische Fortschritt schon so weit
dass man zu kobaltfreien Batterien sich
entwickelt und deshalb muss man einfach
sagen für die Energiewende die wir
brauchen brauchen wir keinen
Tiefseebergbau die Tiefsee Paradies oder
Industriegebiet bis Ende Juli wird die
meeresbodenbehörde verhandeln und
entscheiden
Ausgang ungewiss
[Musik]
mit Sport und zunächst zur
Fußball-Bundesliga da steht nach diesem
25 Spieltag Borussia Dortmund an der
Tabellenspitze Bayern München zweiter
nach der heutigen 1 zu 2 Niederlage
gegen Bayer Leverkusen Union Berlin hat
2:0 gegen Eintracht Frankfurt gewonnen
Mainz und Freiburg trennten sich
unentschieden 1 zu 1
in der Formel 1 heute Große Preis von
Saudi Arabien gewonnen hat in China
Sergio Perez vor Max Verstappen also
Doppelsieg für Red Bull dritter wurde
Mercedes Pilot George Russo nach dem
Fernando Alonso durch eine Zeitstrafe
auf Platz 4 zurückgerutschte
das deutsche langlauf-team hat im
schwedischen Fall und das erste
staffel-podest für den DSV im Weltcup
seit mehr als sechs Jahren geholt Rang 3
war es am Ende mixed Bewerber auf der 4
x 5 km Strecke hinter Schweden und
Norwegen beim Weltcup Finale der
Biathleten in Oslo war heute kein
Podestplatz für die Deutschen zu holen
gefeiert wurde trotzdem und zwar Denise
Hermann Wick sie beendete heute ihre
überaus erfolgreiche Karriere die
34-Jährige landete beim Massenstart auf
Rang 6 Team Kollegin Hanna kebinger auf
Platz 4 Hermann Wiki 2016 vom Langlauf
zum Biathlon gewechselt ist hat
zahlreiche Erfolge feiern können neben
dem Olympiasieg in Peking auch zweimal
WM Gold und 9 deutsche
Meisterschaftstitel
bleiben noch beim Wintersport wenn den
Frauen die Hälfte des Himmels gehört
mindestens dann sollen sie an diesem
Himmel auch fliegen dürfen sagen
jedenfalls die skispringerin die heute
erstmals auch fliegen durften sie haben
sich hart erkämpft dass dieser Sport nun
auch für Frauen geöffnet wird heute also
Premiere mit dem ersten Skifliegen der
Frauen im norwegischen Vikersund
der Entscheidung des Welt Skiverbands
waren lange Debatten vorangegangen
kritiker warnten dass Frauen beim Ski
fliegen noch größere Risiken eingehen
als männlicher Athleten Victoria
Kunzmann und Petra Auto berichten
sie darf als erste runter Yuki Ito aus
Japan von der monsterbackenschanze in
Norwegen auch drei Deutsche sind dabei
beim ersten offiziellen Skifliegen der
Frauen einer Ruprecht Selina Freitag und
Katharina Althaus die am Ende vierte
wird und sie sie fliegt und fliegt und
fliegt Weltrekord 226 Meter heute die
beste Netz fast 8 Sekunden in der Luft
davon träumten viele von ihnen schon so
lange
es gibt einfach im Moment kein geileres
Gefühl als fliegen wir waren eben genau
die gleichen Rechte haben wie die Herren
und dafür kämpfen halt Sie wollen
fliegen aber sie haben Respekt vor
dieser nicht enden wollenden Schanze
denn Fehler verzeiht dieser Sport nicht
Frauen brauchen mehr Anlauf um weit
genug und sicher zu fliegen sie rasen
noch schneller als Männer auf den
Sprungtisch zu mit mehr als 100 km/h da
wird Kritik laut von Männern
ein Sturz werden sie beim Aufprall
höhere Geschwindigkeiten haben als
Männer dass der erste Grund warum die
verletzungswahrscheinlichkeit größer
sein wird der zweite Grund liegt im
Unterschied zwischen Mann und Frau dann
Muskelanteil ist biologisch ein Mann
etwas größer das heißt er hat eine
größere Pufferzone heute ist alles gut
gegangen die Frauen haben gezeigt dass
sie wie die Männer Skifliegen können
auch wenn manche Ängste bleiben
muss jetzt noch unser Ausblick auf die
nächste Woche Laura warnick beginnt mit
einem Staatsbesuch bei dem die Welt sehr
genau hinschauen wird
[Musik]
am Montag wird China Staats- und
Parteichef hier erstmals seit fast vier
Jahren Russland besuchen bis Mittwoch
werden sich Putin und China über ihre
strategische und praktische
Zusammenarbeit beraten ebenso sollen der
russische Angriffskrieg gegen die
Ukraine und militärstrategische Themen
eine Rolle spielen
außerdem wird der Weltklimarat der
Vereinten Nationen seinen Bericht zum
Klimawandel vorstellen dem zufolge waren
die Experten davor das 1,5 Grad Ziel bei
der Erderwärmung weiter zu verfehlen
Folgen wie Wassermangel und
Umweltkatastrophen würden dadurch weiter
drastisch zunehmen am Mittwoch beginnt
bei den Muslimen der jährliche
Fastenmonat die Gläubigen werden von
Sonnenaufgang des Sonnenuntergang wieder
trinken noch essen der Ramadan ist ein
zentrales Element der Religion und endet
mit dem dreitägigen Zuckerfest am 21
April
in New York wird die zweite
un-wasserkonferenz zu Ende gehen 46
Jahre nach dem ersten Treffen durch
Klimawandel und Bevölkerungswachstum
sind die Wasserressourcen knapper denn
je
Bundesumweltministerin Lemke spricht von
einer globalen Wasserkrise und will in
New York die deutsche wasserstrategie
vorstellen
und die Wetteraussichten zum Start in
die neue Woche sind so morgen gibt es
anfangs im Südosten Schauer am
Nachmittag regnet es im Norden sonst
bleibt es trocken mit der meisten Sonne
im Südwesten 11 bis 17 Grad an den
Küsten ist des Kühler in den nächsten
Tagen ändert sich an den Temperaturen
nur wenig am Dienstag regnet es in der
Nordhälfte danach häufige auch im Süden
ab Mittwoch wird ein lebhafter
Südwestwind
und damit verabschieden wir uns an
diesen Sonntagabend morgen erwarten Sie
hier Christian Sievers und Hanna
Zimmermann und um 0.30 gibt es die
nächste heute Express einen schönen
Abend noch auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]